welcome to hannity and tonight bezo
belto bozo o'rourke is back and not
doing very well he seems very angry uh
use a lot of cuss words and we'll play
the tape coming up but first we do have
serious news to begin our night and to
come
behind enemy lines day 59
day 59 americans are allies their
families green card holders totally
completely utterly abandoned by your
president joe biden behind enemy lines
hostages to terrorists joe hasn't even
mentioned these innocent men women and
children in over 40 days he's he's
turned the page as he says and now the
biden administration they are planning
to send more money to let's see oh
that's right the professional and
business-like taliban terrorists they're
calling it humanitarian aid but in
reality where i grew up that looks an
awful lot like a massive ransom payment
to terrorists now tonight it's clear
everything biden touches becomes an
unmitigated disaster i can't cite a
single success afghanistan is a huge
massive crisis unprecedented uh i've
never seen or thought i'd see this in my
life look at the border another
catastrophe covid 19 is now worse under
biden despite being gifted three
vaccines a vaccine distribution program
a wealth of knowledge about therapeutics
monoclonal antibodies among them the
economy is now a complete and utter
train wreck we have a lot of details
we'll give you especially for low and
middle class and middle-income americans
we have inflation shortages unemployment
we will detail all the latest troubling
statistics it's chilling actually and
perhaps of all the worst of all joe gave
in to the environmental extremists and
he abandoned the energy independence at
that donald trump handed him and now all
of us all of you are suffering because
of it police health care workers first
responders teachers yeah many are now
being forced out of their jobs they are
leaving
in the middle of an employment shortage
all because of joe's vaccine mandates i
thought if we got the vaccine we
protected ourselves apparently like with
everything else coveted related with
pouchy and and biden it changes daily
with multiple major crises spiraling out
of control americans are turning on the
biden white house three new polls show
joe biden underwater by double digits
according to gallup biden's support
among independents it is now cratered to
just 37 percent and now anti-biden
chance they are breaking out in stadiums
and sporting events talladega at the
ryder cup football games nationwide take
a look
[Applause]
and that is not the only anti-biden
chant that is now trending across the
country let's go brandon that's also a
new favorite among americans because of
this special moment on nbc you have a
nascar driver winning a big race brandon
brown after his big victory at talladega
well the reporter actually thinks
they're saying cheering brandon but when
you listen closely
no they're not take a look just such an
unbelievable
moment
brandon you also told me
you can hear the chance from the
crowd
let's go brandon
no they weren't chanting let's go
brandon at all you the american people
have every reason to be angry at joe
biden he is failing this country around
every turn every american is paying the
price the world is paying the price
inflation is now costing american
families households 175 dollars extra
every month in other words that is a two
thousand one hundred dollar annual tax
on every single household in the country
regardless of income compliments of joe
biden's horrific economic policies the
cost of eggs meat poultry fish that's up
nearly 20 percent on top of uh meat and
processed meat guess what a predictor
that steak will now become a
champagne-like luxury only available to
the wealthy and the ceo of kraft heinz
they're warning that rising food prices
are not going away meanwhile look at
this the cost of cotton is up a whopping
47 percent to date that is a 10-year
high right now we have a 30-year high in
terms of inflation indicators in other
words any clothing you buy has cotton in
it or plan on buying is going to cost a
lot more the cost of raw materials also
surging the cost of motor vehicles car
parts is surging almost every single
thing you buy is now more expensive at
the core of all of this massive
inflation rising energy costs and gas
prices all caused by joe biden and one
of his first acts as president joe biden
artificially reduced america's oil and
gas supply capabilities and in the same
time he literally
lowered the supply chain of the
lifeblood of the world's economy energy
in the stroke of one pen he halted the
keystone pipeline and he gave vladimir
putin yes a special waiver to build his
pipeline as a result natural gas prices
are up a whopping
112 percent since january biden is
making russia rich again oil prices are
up 65 percent five dollar a gallon
gasoline is now a reality in new york
california and soon probably a gas
station near you of course diesel prices
they're also surging everything that you
buy in every store gets there via truck
those trucks they use diesel now these
extra transportation costs they're going
to be passed on to you part of the biden
inflation tax the consumer add to this
another major problem that's america's
supply chain that's in a state of chaos
because of america's work shortage
worker shortage cargo ships off the
coast in california new york they're
piling up unable to unload their
containers meanwhile goods are now
piling up in warehouses because of a
lack of drivers now nationwide shortages
that's become the norm walmart costco
they're now rationing toilet paper tires
are becoming hard to find for your car
or truck look at your screen grocery
store shelves are going empty in some
places those images from tennessee
economists are warning many christmas
presents for your kids they're not going
to be arriving in time for the holiday
season even more troubling a looming
shortage of school bus drivers one
transportation expert is now predicting
this driver shortage alone will remain
severe all year long and as you can see
the economy another biden preventable
catastrophe yet joe biden as fellow
democrats they're just determined to
make it worse and worse with trillions
of new spending and new new taxes that
will be passed on to you that is a move
that will cause inflation to skyrocket
even more but as jen saki explained
earlier today democrats never let a
crisis go to waste take a look
the president wants to make fundamental
change in our economy and he feels
coming out of the pandemic is exactly
the time to do that and if we don't do
it now if we don't address
the cost of child care to go back to
josh's question earlier if we don't
address the climate crisis if we don't
ensure that universal pre-k is a reality
now
uh we're we're not going to have the
same opportunity to do it for some time
we won't have the opportunity to do it
for some time because hopefully you get
voted out in the midterms anyway sadly
the new green deal socialist spending
programs that's what we need to worry
about and we cannot afford the trillions
of dollars they're going to borrow and
spend governor newsom out in california
he's now even banning gas powered lawn
mowers and chainsaws in california i
hope they don't do that to weed whackers
i love my weed whacker and the biden
administration's new vaccine mandates
are forcing thousands of teachers police
officers first responders health care
workers and yes our military are opting
out of their jobs in the middle of a
pandemic a nationwide worker shortage on
top of it one positive development a
federal judge ruled in favor of health
care workers seeking a religious
exemption from the vaccine mandate over
the weekend southwest airlines they were
forced to cancel more than a thousand
flights because of a suspected sick out
protest against the company's new
vaccine mandate and that's not stopping
the biden administration or the great
flip-flop i've been wrong on pretty much
everything dr fauci you know the guy
that helped fund the wuhan virology lab
from floating a truly insane mandate for
all americans that want to fly on a
commercial airplane take a look
would you like a vaccine mandate for air
travel and effect for the holidays
well it depends on what you mean if
you're talking you know we do now have a
situation
when people coming in from outside of
the country who are not united states
citizens they really must require that
they get vaccinated as well as getting
tested before
on the table is the issue of mandates
for vaccine it's always discussable we
always wind up discussing do you support
it but right now i don't see that
immediately you know dan i don't want to
say support or not i think it it's a
decision that's made by input from a
number of parts of the government
including public health
all right soon if joe biden gets his way
millions of americans will not be able
to get a job or even travel but don't
worry i'm sure that they will have no
impact on our already struggling economy
right and at the center of our current
economic crisis yep there is the weak
frail cognitively struggling mess
clueless joe biden experiencing even
more cognitive decline today another 3
p.m early afternoon lid he needed his
nappy time and joel while he's asleep at
the wheel as radical advisors they just
take over who they are we don't know and
they want to fundamentally reshape this
country and they're saying so they want
to upend the greatest economic uh engine
on the face of this earth the greatest
wealth creating system on the face of
the earth they want open borders they
want amnesty they want womb to the tomb
cradle to grave entitlements we cannot
afford for every single person unable or
unwilling to work they want to turn the
united states of america into their
socialist leftist status utopia and they
must be stopped at the ballot box before
it's too late hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else